[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN BELCHER: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for joining.
I'm Dan Belcher.
I'm one of the founders of
a new startup called mabl.
And this is Joe Lust,
one of our engineers.
First off, I want to
thank you for coming.
I know we're competing
against lunch and the keynote
with Diane Greene
and Jeff Deans.
So, you must all be as excited
about testing as I am, right?
Right?
Yeah, OK.
Good.
Yeah, Woo-hoo!
So we're here to talk about
the future of software testing
and the relationship
between testing and GCP.
And so one thing I do want to
note, I am a former Googler.
So I'm in recovery.
I left in the
beginning of last year.
What it means is that I get
to use the same infrastructure
that I used to use
when I was at Google,
but now I have to pay them
a lot of money for it.
But I'm happy to be here.
We're a very happy Google
customer as I bet many of you
are.
So mabl, we started that company
about a year and a half ago.
And we started basically with
a very broad sort of approach.
And we interviewed
hundreds of software teams.
And we would sit
down and ask them
basically, well, what's working
well, what's not working well.
And we heard a bunch of things.
So we heard that as
an industry, we're
moving toward
continuous integration,
continuous delivery, DevOps.
Raise your hand if you
have a lot of work underway
to move to DevOps, CI/CD?
Yeah, all right.
So we're all going there.
Raise your hand if you
feel like you're done,
everything's going great.
Hey, one, two, three, good.
And so another
thing that we heard
was that there is an emerging
bottleneck in that journey.
And that's around
software testing.
And so the thesis
that we developed
is actually that
software testing
needs to evolve if
we as an industry
can achieve the potential
of DevOps and CI/CD.
And so we set out to build mabl.
And this quote
left a mark on me.
One of the QA
leaders that we spent
a lot of time with very
early on said, hey Dan,
let me just put
it very directly.
My teams are shipping
features at a pace
now that I can't keep up.
There is just not
enough time to test.
Does that sound familiar,
I'm sure, to some of you?
And so we figured
out-- we thought, well,
how can we help him solve this?
And what we believe is that
we've reached a tipping point,
as you start to approach
continuous integration,
continuous delivery,
where fundamentally
the ways that we've
thought about QA
historically don't
really apply anymore.
I actually bumped into a former
colleague, Marius back there.
Where's Marius?
Marius, he and I were sitting
in a room probably 13 years ago
planning our annual release
at Microsoft, right?
And so we would talk about, OK,
how many months, how many weeks
do we need for QA
for this release?
And we'd work through a
detailed plan incorporating
all the changes that we expected
to happen to the product based
on a functional spec.
A lot of people are in
functional specs these days?
Yeah, a little bit?
And now, we're at a point
in many environments,
or at least we want
to get to a place
where change is just continuous.
So you can't plan for
a given change anymore.
It's continuous.
We're talking about an order
of magnitude more releases.
And so the challenge
to us as an industry
is, how can we achieve that
velocity while still having
confidence that we're delivering
high-quality product to our end
users?
So this is an illustration
actually of our team at mabl.
So we only have, I
don't know, a handful
of people contributing
to this project, which
is our UI project.
And we're doing, I don't
know, as many as 100 commits
that get pushed to
production every single week.
And this is a little team.
Now imagine where
orders of magnitude,
as I know many of your teams
are orders of magnitude larger.
So think of that pace of change.
How can we make sure that we're
shipping high-quality product?
And these aren't small changes.
We're talking about
thousands, tens of thousands
of lines of code, shipping to
production every single week.
And this is to ignore
the fact that we
update dependencies, configs,
and so forth every single day.
And that's all change
that could lead
to a broken product for users.
And so the challenge
to us is, how do we
maintain this velocity while
achieving good confidence
that we can trust the product
that goes out the door
and maintain our users
trust based on that?
And to make the challenge
even greater as QA leaders,
as VPs of engineering,
we are being
tasked to make sure
that our products work
on more devices, more browsers,
more resolutions, more
permutations of the client
experience than ever before.
And so now you think
about that QA leader
that has this pace of change
that's just unbelievable coming
into the team.
And on top of that,
we're being tasked
to say, let's make
sure that it works
across a wide
variety of devices.
And so some teams are struggling
to say, how do I build out
the infrastructure that
I need to make sure
that I can test effectively
across all the client
experiences that
I have to support?
And the risk is that
we end up in a position
where the QA function or process
is a bottleneck for development
teams.
And so think about all
the innovation that's
happened over the last 10 years,
development tools and processes
that enable you as an engineer
to build and ship code faster,
think of all the
great innovations that
have happened in the
DevOps space for you
as a sys admin or an
operator to release
that code to production, and
monitor it, and manage it.
Well, where's the
innovation for QA?
And so this is what
we're focused on.
And we actually
believe that we're
at the beginning of
a new era of what
we call intelligent testing.
And really, this is
intelligent test automation.
And there are some principles
that we believe in here.
The first one is that tests have
to be able to adapt to change.
And what that means is
as the product evolves,
it has to be very infrequent
that the tests blow up
because of a change to the
product that doesn't actually
affect the user experience.
The second principle is that
we think that tests are going
to be running in the cloud.
We'll talk in a minute
about how automated testing,
like the execution
of automated tests,
is the perfect use case
for cloud computing.
Third, we'll talk about how
the tests that get executed,
the output, that we can't be
in the business of reviewing
the output of every
test execution
that goes by to confirm
that there aren't issues,
we need to apply analysis
to that output to tell us
when there are issues.
And that's a really
important shift.
And then finally,
this all has to happen
in the context of a pipeline.
We can't have QA sort
of off to the side
trying to inspect releases as
they go through because again,
the pace is such that it has
to be automatic and automated.
So those are the principles.
And what we'll do
now is we'll explore
each principle in
detail and show you
how it works when we
integrate with GCP.
GCP actually provides a
really compelling foundation
for solving a lot
of these problems.
And so the first
principle was tests
have to be able to
adapt to change.
If any of you have worked with
legacy testing frameworks,
you've probably
struggled a little bit
with tests that can survive
changes to your front end,
for example.
Anybody work with
Selenium, Selenium?
Yeah, OK.
And anybody built great
Selenium test suite
that can seamlessly
handle dramatic changes
to the front end
without false positives?
Not one hand.
Maybe an elbow back there.
Yeah, almost.
Oh, down, that was thumbs down.
And so, one of the
problems we need to solve
is exactly this, to
make sure that tests
don't break when the user
experience isn't affected.
Because when you
have that situation,
and you're trying to deploy
changes for production rapidly,
false positives and
tests can create
all sorts of dysfunction.
Either you stop the
release, creating a backup
in the pipeline, or you end
up with developers saying,
hey QA, your tests,
those are bad tests.
And QA is saying, well,
you broke the test.
Why don't you go fix it?
Anybody been in that-- we've
been in that situation.
I don't even have to ask.
And so, we created mabl
just as an illustration
to be intent-driven.
And so what that means is
we use a Chrome extension.
And as a QA engineer, or a
product owner, or a support
person, or anyone else, you
basically use your application
as you would expect
end users to,
and then mabl captures
the intent of your actions
and generates tests
based on that.
And we'll talk about how
that works in just a second.
An important thing here is
to look at the area in red
where it says, "click
the Close Alert button."
And so that's just a step
that mabl recorded as you
were using the application.
Now, when we run that
test in the cloud,
it could be that when
we get to that step--
so you look at the area
that's highlighted in red--
that that button now says,
"Dismiss" and the XPath
changed.
The XPath is the location
of that button in the DOM,
the structure of the web page.
Now historically, this would
be a disaster for your test
because anything that interacted
with that button would fail.
What we've done with
mabl is implemented
a set of heuristics that
say, OK, given the intent
to click that button,
let's go figure out
how to find the
button if we can't
find it using the locators
that we had originally.
And so we've built a model of
that button and every element
that we interact with.
And so, if we can't find the
button where it used to be
we'll find the button using
a different heuristic,
and we'll make sure that
the test continues to pass.
And then if it does,
we'll update the test.
And so this is an
example of how you
can create tests
that can survive
these dramatic and
frequent changes
in at least the front
end of an application.
And so Joe will
talk a little bit
about how we do that on GCP.
JOSEPH LUST: Thanks Dan.
So as Dan was saying, and
as any developer here knows,
the real problem with
continuous testing
these days is brittle tests.
You check in to commit,
6,000 tests fail.
So we really do need to make
these tests automatically
adapt.
And not only do we make
them automatically adapt,
the system has to adapt because
nobody can go through 6,000
tests to fix that CSS bug.
So here at mabl is how in GCP
we built a continuous, seamless
adaptation workflow.
We start with everything
in the bottom right
here, the Cloud Datastore,
which is our storage
place for all the scripts
that we're going to run,
all the tests.
And then these tests get
loaded into our testing cluster
in Kubernetes,
which is going to be
able to run hundreds of parallel
instances of that browser.
And they're all going to emit
tons of observations, hundreds
a second, as Dan
mentioned how we're
building that model of
that page, of that element.
And this continuous flow
goes through Cloud Pub/Sub
and into Cloud Dataflow.
We can do continuous
stream processing
and transforms on this data.
And we can determine,
did something odd happen?
Did we not find the button?
Did it change its
text, but we think
we know where it really is?
And in some cases, we
might not know where it is.
In that case, we would go
out to Cloud Functions.
We can call a script,
send a Slack message,
let our user know that
something has gone wrong.
But in most cases,
we can actually
start closing this loop.
We can figure out that Dismiss
is actually the correct button.
And we can automatically
change that script and say,
this is the button
you need to click.
And we can feed back
into our data store,
we can update that script,
and the next time we run,
we know exactly where it is, and
we don't have to adapt again.
The test has been healed.
And by doing this,
this continuous flow,
we seamlessly adapt and are able
to achieve continuous testing.
DAN BELCHER: Great,
thank you very much, Joe.
And so that's how-- that's
a general pattern for how
we can create tests that
survive despite changes
to the structure of
the underlying page.
So practically speaking,
what this means
is that for our users,
putting a maintenance message
at the top of the
page that changes
the DOM and the XPaths of
all the elements on the page
doesn't break the tests.
Changing the IDs of elements
doesn't break the test.
Changing the CSS classes
don't break the test.
And so that makes
it so that you don't
have a lot of noise around sort
of maintaining the test as part
of the pipeline.
So that's the first principle.
Second principle, tests
will run in the cloud.
We predict that
three years from now,
we're sitting here talking.
And if I ask how many
people are building out
big farms of test
infrastructure for on-premise,
we think very few hands
are going to go up.
And really, that's because,
as I mentioned before,
testing is a great use case
for cloud infrastructure.
It's a much more efficient
way to run tests.
And so let's just talk
some numbers here.
So imagine your web
application, you only
had 50 test cases or scripts
that you want to run.
I'm sure many of you have orders
of magnitude more than that,
but let's start
small, so 50 things.
Let's say I want
to add some items
to a cart I want to checkout.
Let me search, let me sign up,
register, so on and so forth,
like the core of
a web application.
Now, let's imagine
for each of those,
you only want to test, on
average, three scenarios,
so users with
different permissions,
or in different locations, or
different credit card numbers,
and so forth.
So, let's say just three.
Now, you want to support
probably the four
major browsers,
let's say, and maybe
the current version and
one previous version, so
eight browser versions.
And then, you have
three environments,
so you deploy to QA, and
then staging, and then prod.
And you want to test
every time you deploy.
And then you do
three releases a day,
which may sound like, oh my god,
that's an incredible velocity
to many of you.
And then to some others you'd
say, well, you mean just me,
not my whole team?
But in this world where
you're deploying about once
every eight hours, you're
talking about nearly 11,000
tests being executed a day.
So this is real volume
generated from trying
to get decent coverage
across only 50 tests.
Now, if you wanted to look at--
let's say, we ran--
we created tests that run pretty
quickly, seven minutes each
on average, you're talking
about nearly 1,300 compute hours
dedicated to
executing these tests.
And you're talking about
a very, very simple test
suite and set of scenarios.
So this is real infrastructure
that we need to deal with.
Where it gets kind
of crazy is when
you think about the
concurrency that's
required in order to execute
those tests within target
windows.
So if you're doing a
release every eight hours,
and you want to run those
tests that we talked
about in the prior
slide, then sure,
if you had 54 nodes of compute,
executing tests in parallel,
you could churn through
them in about eight hours,
so before you do your
next release, not too bad.
Now, Joe doesn't like to
sit around for eight hours
after he does a deployment
to wait to find out
if the tests passed.
In fact, he wouldn't
even tolerate an hour.
But if it was an
hour, he would--
we need about 420
nodes of compute
to be able to run all
those tests within an hour
after the deployment.
Now, what we expect, and
what I think many of you
expect when we get to that
vision of continuous delivery,
is that we're
talking about minutes
to execute the entire test suite
because you want your engineers
to be able to get that
code in production,
and move on to the
next task, and not
deal with a bunch
of work in progress.
And so here we're talking
about 3,600 nodes of compute
to execute those 50 simple
scripts for this application.
But the reason why
this is a perfect use
case for cloud computing
is because for how long
do you need those 3,600
nodes of compute, the line
in green here?
You need them for
about 10 minutes.
And so why would you deal
with previsions, capacity,
to execute those tests?
You want to burst,
run the tests,
and then make it disappear.
And the efficiency is
basically the entire chart
because you're only paying
for the green spikes.
You're not paying for the rest.
That's the most efficient model
for executing those tests.
And we can show you
exactly how to do it.
JOSEPH LUST: Thanks Dan.
So let's say you're
on the bandwagon,
you want to build your
cloud-centric, scalable
Selenium-testing framework
Well, lucky for you,
Google Cloud Platform has
Google Kubernetes Engine.
Now, I need to give
you a disclaimer.
This won't let you
test everything.
Some browsers are limited
by their architectures
or licenses, like
Internet Explorer, Safari
on Mac, iOS, and Android.
But excluding those, you can
still run a very robust set up
in the cloud.
So for example, you could use
Selenium Docker project images
of Firefox and Chrome
and schedule them
on your Google Kubernetes
Engine instances as pods.
And Kubernetes is
now is automatically
going to find a home for
each one of those pods.
It's going to start stacking
them up in instances.
It's going to
efficiently pack them.
And if it can't find a
home, add more instances,
and keep adding
instances until it
can run all those tests,
all 10,000, for example.
But then when they're
done, it's going
to start getting rid of nodes,
scale all the way back down
to zero.
This makes it highly efficient,
highly cost effective.
And it's actually
all very much no ops.
It just works.
So at mabl, for example, we have
many such Kubernetes clusters.
But last year, we
set up one of them.
And to date, it's run about
12 million containers.
And it really hasn't
been touched in a year.
It automatically gets upgraded,
automatically maintained.
It's a very, very robust set up.
We like to think
about Ron Popeil
when we look at our cluster.
We just say, set
it and forget it.
Now again, using
these tools, you
are easily able to take
your Selenium infrastructure
and just seamlessly
scale it in the cloud.
DAN BELCHER: Great.
So what Joe will
show us next is how
we've implemented that in mabl.
So imagine you didn't want to
provision your own Kubernetes
architecture and deal with
the scheduling, and execution,
and all that yourself,
if you were to use mabl,
let's show them how that
would work in real time
if we could bring up the demo.
JOSEPH LUST: Sure.
So what we have
right here now is
an example of what we
call a test plan in mabl.
In this case, we're
just going to kick it
off hitting the "Run" button.
And what's just happened is
our pods, as you can see here
for Chrome and for
Firefox, have been sent off
to be scheduled on the
Kubernetes cluster.
Actual browsers
are being spun up.
And then we actually here
have our different tests.
So for example, we
have "find a shirt."
And we can see in this case,
we're going to go to Nordstrom,
we're going to look
for men's shirts,
and we're going to assert that
we found the proper shirt.
And what's going to happen
is that mabl's going
to make all those permutations.
It's going to make two
tests, two browsers.
So four containers
are going to spin up.
And we can see them
all right here.
Looks like they took off about
30 seconds ago all running
in parallel.
And what's going to
happen is mabl is
making all those observations
we showed you earlier,
taking all the screenshots,
learning everything she can
about this given
application under test,
taking screenshots, and
letting us do all of this just
in parallel, much more
scalable than anything
you generally would
be able to find when
you're running your own set up.
And here we are.
We've already gone through--
we started finding pants.
And we are scaling
very well in the cloud.
We have the slides, Ken?
DAN BELCHER: Thank you, Joe.
And so that's what we're talking
about when we talk about tests
being the sort of--
automated testing
being the ideal workload
for cloud computing.
We can kick off a test, fan
out, run that test in parallel,
turn the resources
off, and only pay
for the resources for that
very short period of time
that we needed them
to execute the test.
You also noticed it's the
Anniversary sale at Nordstrom
here.
So, the third
principle, test results
need to be more insightful.
And so the core
there is as we're
executing tens of thousands
of tests over a given release
cycle, or quarter,
or year, we can't
be dealing with each test
run as a special snowflake.
Joe would never go
into an application
and look at those
logs of the test
to make sure that it's
running effectively.
What he needs to know is,
did I break the product?
And otherwise, he's going
to be on to the next feature
that he's working on.
And so, how do we do that?
Well, one principle for us with
making test results insightful
is we think, what would
mabl as a persona do?
If mabl is a manual
tester, would mabl only
look at the HTML of the page?
And is the HTML doing
what it's supposed to do?
Probably not.
Would mabl only look
at the screenshots
and see if the screenshots
were appropriate?
Probably not.
Mabl would want to look at a
variety of aspects of quality
of the application and
then decide whether it
works or not based on those.
And so what we've done
is built a pipeline that
can capture all these
different types of data,
we feed that data into
an analytics pipeline,
and then we generate insights
based on either heuristics
or models that we've
implemented to detect
when the application's
not performing
as we expected that it should.
And so here is a good example.
We have some very
simple insights.
We can use basic heuristics.
Many of you could
build this one where
we attempt to click on every
link in an application.
And we have
heuristics that says,
if there's a new broken
link, why don't we
tell Joe about it and say,
your last build actually
broke some links, simple stuff.
The next one, client-side
JavaScript errors.
So, we'll capture client-side
JavaScript errors,
associate them with
each step in the test.
And the important
thing here is letting
people know when there's
a change versus the model
or state that we
have of the page.
So many of you probably have
lots of client-side JavaScript
errors when we load the
app that don't actually
hurt the end user.
And so we're not going to
tell you again, and again,
and again we saw again in this
test, wake up at 3 o'clock
in the morning because
you have some errors.
But what you might want
to know is when I just did
a deployment that
I'm now on step four,
there are new errors.
And so this gives you a way
of preventing technical debt
from accruing with these errors.
And so these are two
heuristics-driven insights
that this pipeline gives us.
Another one, model-driven
insights around anomalies.
So think of timing.
So I'm able as a manual
QA engineer would probably
love to be able to detect
subtle changes in page load
time or test execution time.
But that's a challenging
thing for us to do as humans,
running test after test
unless you have a stopwatch.
But you're not in control
of all of your actions.
So what mabl will do is
captures timing information--
page load time, test execution
time, step time, and so forth--
and then predicts
how long it will take
the next time we run a test.
And if the actual observation is
different than the prediction,
then we surface an insight.
And of course, Google
Cloud, and machine learning
play an important part in that.
The feature that
people are perhaps
most excited about
right now with us
is detecting visual anomalies.
And so our Nordstrom
colleagues in the audience
will appreciate this one.
When we search for those pants--
we started the test a
couple of days ago--
It was the preview of
the Anniversary sale.
And then a couple of days
later, we ran the test,
and the Anniversary
sale had been launched.
And so what changed?
You can barely see it.
But the menus is
at the top changed.
And that was the first
time mabl had ever
seen those menus changed.
And so she flagged
it as an anomaly,
as an anomalous change.
Now what you can't really
see-- you could barely see here
is when I run that
search for women's
pants, the order
of the pants change
every time you on the test.
There's a random aspect
to how those load.
And so mabl has
to be smart enough
to detect expected changes
from unexpected changes.
And so the model actually takes
these dynamic areas and says,
while these are
dynamic regions, I'm
not going to surface visual
anomalies in those regions
because they change
too frequently,
whereas there are these
other regions that
are predictably the same
every time I run the test.
And if I see those
change, then I'll
surface that as an insight.
And so these are
the type of insights
that we're trying to drive
toward in this new era where
we're giving you actionable,
relevant information
so that then you
can dive in when
there are potential issues.
But it takes a lot of work.
Thankfully, we have
some infrastructure
that we can rely on.
JOSEPH LUST: Thanks Dan.
So as Dan points out, one of
these major limiting factors
we have with tests in general is
that they make a lot of noise.
As a developer, the last thing
you want is yet another report.
Here is 6,000 things you
need to fix right now.
So what comes out of this
process has to be insightful.
But also like in mabl when
we're running on Scale and GCP,
we have to handle tons
and tons of inputs
and figure out which ones
of those are insights.
And more importantly, we
have to tune them down
to the exact insight for
that specific customer,
whether it's insightful to them.
So we start, as you saw earlier,
with our Kubernetes Engine,
which is churning through
thousands of web pages,
making our continuous feed
of observations coming out.
And then we feed it into
several different pipelines.
The first pipeline is our
continuous prediction pipeline.
Here, we harness Cloud Dataflow,
again, to work on the data,
transform it is necessary.
And we feed it into Cloud ML.
And in the Cloud
Machine Learning,
we run our models against,
for example, those images
or against timing, and we
decide, did this change?
Is this a visual anomaly?
Or did this get too
slow or too fast?
And if that is the case,
then we immediately
push via Pub/Sub
to Cloud Functions
so we can notify our user.
We want to do that immediately
so it's a timely insight.
And that, for example,
is sent out over Slack.
So within about a second
or two from hitting
that URL, observing, we popped
up a message in your Slack
saying, we found something
is going way, way too slow.
Yes or no, is this good?
But we can't just tell you that.
We want to take that feedback
back into the machine
because the machine
needs to understand
what's important to you.
So in this case,
Cloud Functions lets
us have an endpoint that
takes that Slack feedback back
in when you click on the,
yes, this is a good insight,
or no, it's not, and
we feed that back
into another pipeline, our
continuous training pipeline.
We can do a little
bit of cleanup,
for example, in Cloud Dataflow.
And then again by
Cloud Machine Learning,
we can update that model,
make it adapt to you
and tune your insights.
We won't give you an insight
that's not insightful to you
in the future.
We put this back in
the Cloud Datastore.
And that data store
is the reference
of all of these models,
so we now have a circle.
And we are continuously
training, and predicting,
and training.
Another limiting
factor sometimes
with creating these
sorts of insights
is maybe you have
a new model, and we
need to change that model.
We need to maybe go back
through a 100 million pictures
and retrain against all of them.
That can be very prohibitive
from a scaling standpoint.
But using, for example,
Kubernetes Engine,
we can take a brand
new Python ML script,
we can, as we did at mabl
this week, spin 400 machines,
crush all of those
millions of images,
update everybody's models.
And now, we have been
able to push something out
that would have been very
challenging previously back
into our continuous prediction
and training pipeline.
All this being
perfectly serverless,
each one of these components
able to scale up and down
independently with
NoOps and us, all
through using these
different serverless
technologies in Google Cloud.
DAN BELCHER: Thanks Joe.
So, if you wanted to build
this, you just do this, right?
It's not that hard.
JOSEPH LUST: It's great.
DAN BELCHER: I mean, I
think the staggering thing
for me is to think about where
we are as an industry today.
And while this has taken
some work to build,
for a team, PhDs making
this stuff happen,
imagine what it would have
taken 10 years ago, where
none of these services
existed, or at least were
available to us publicly
outside of Google.
And so it's actually making it
possible to solve some problems
in a very elegant way
that weren't really
possible to solve
before unless you
were running at incredible
scale, Google scale
or what have you.
And so that was the
third principle,
that test results need
to be more insightful.
And then the final
one is testing then
needs to be part of a
continuous delivery pipeline.
So QA can't be off to the side.
It needs to be fully automated
part of the pipeline.
And what a pipeline
might look like is
something like this, right Joe?
We're write some code.
He'll commit it.
We'll do a build,
execute some unit tests.
Once that's ready to go, we'll
deploy to a QA environment.
That deployment generates--
triggers some tests.
Once those all pass,
then we promote
that build to a
staging environment
or deployed to a
staging environment.
Then we run some
tests on staging.
If those pass, we
deploy to prod,
and then we'll do some
final smoke tests in prod.
So let's see what that
looks like at scale.
JOSEPH LUST: So as a
quick overview of the demo
we're going to do,
we're going to show you
how we can create
continuous testing
and continuous deployment
workflows tied together to get
us a testing feedback loop.
In this case, we have a
CodeCommit, perhaps to GitHub.
That can then trigger
a deployment trigger
in Cloud Build, which is
going to automatically
go get our code from Git.
It's going to build
it, deploy it, tell
mabl there's a new deployment
available via its API.
That will then come
back and test our app.
And if it's successful, it
can call back to Cloud Build
and keep propagating through
our deploy, test, deploy, test,
deploy, test cycle.
So, to show you what that
works like, if we could please
get the demo laptop.
The first thing
we need is an app
because we have to
deploy something
for our continuous deployment.
So in this case, we have
calc.mabl.com, a very primitive
calculator where we can
do things like addition.
Now, this demo is going to start
like all great code deployments
start, with a merge.
So we have our
live Lucky demo PR.
Let's hope this works.
Eh, do it.
OK.
So now we've just sent
this off into the ether.
And we're going to be
triggering Cloud Build.
And Cloud Build
should take over now.
And it's discovered that we have
just started the deployment.
And this lets us do
a simple workflow.
For example, we're going to
install our application's
dependencies.
We're going to
build that web app.
We're going to push
it out to Google Cloud
Storage for static hosting.
It's actually going to
give us a dynamic URL.
And then we're going to call
mabl's deployment event API
and feed in that dynamic
URL so we can actually
run that test against
any different location.
If we see there, it
looks like it's almost
done building our web app.
But let's talk about what
it's actually going to do.
So, we've got some more
tests here because, again,
for continuous testing, we're
going to need some tests.
And in this case,
similar to before,
we're going to run across
multiple browsers, Chrome
and Firefox.
And we're going to do
a simple mathematics
test because we need to
make sure the math works
inside that calculator we built.
And so we have some
simple test steps here.
For example, we want to make
sure that 3 plus 3 equals 6.
That's a pretty good invariant.
Hopefully it holds.
But that's only one test.
And a calculator
can do many things.
So we actually have another
feature we're going to use.
Oops, let's see.
And that's called
parametrized testing
because we don't
want to write tons
and tons of different tests.
So here we have something
we call a data table.
So we have 50
different permutations.
And now we can test things
like multiplication, division,
subtraction, negative numbers.
And now we're getting 100 tests.
And all we had to do
is write one test.
[LIGHT APPLAUSE]
So given all that--
oh, thank you.
Thank you.
This feature's live, by the way.
So given all of that, now
mabl has already started,
and our servers are spinning up.
Here they go off to the races.
81, we should get to 100 here
shortly, little bit of a burst.
But again, what's going on?
All these separate
containers are spinning up.
We have 100 instances pumping
in Google Cloud that just turned
on for Firefox, for Chrome.
And they're running all
of our tests in parallel.
And it looks like
they're done now.
So that took under two
minutes, I believe.
And in a classic
environment, that
would have taken three hours.
And all that was driven
this continuous testing,
continues deployment, by
you making a single commit.
DAN BELCHER: Woo!
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSEPH LUST: Slides.
DAN BELCHER: So thank you, Joe.
So we've talked through
the four principles
that we've been
focused on that we
think will underlie this new
era of intelligent testing.
I know that if you
work in the QA space,
there's been some
struggle lately keeping up
with the pace of development.
The good news is there is hope.
We're going to, as an
industry, find a way
to deliver tests that adapt
seamlessly to applications
that change rapidly.
We're going to run those tests
in the cloud at scale and speed
that we haven't seen before,
as Joe's demo just showed us.
We'll have insights based on
output that are actionable,
so we don't have to deal
with the individual results
of every test.
And then also, we'll integrate
deeply into automated pipelines
so that we don't have to
have manual intervention
at every step in
a release process.
And it's all powered by
innovations in cloud computing,
and here, in our
case, in Google Cloud.
And so thank you very much
for your time and attention.
We're here to answer any
questions that you might have.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]